>> Neil: I WANT TO CORRECT
SOMETHING EARLIER.
THAT MEETING IS WRAPPED UP
BETWEEN THE PRESIDENT AND
GOVERNOR CUOMO.
A WRAPPED UP ABOUT 10 MINUTES
AGO.
THERE WAS NO PHOTO ABILITY THAT
BECAME AVAILABLE.
THE GOVERNOR LEFT.
WE WERE TOLD IT WAS AN AMICABLE
DISCUSSION.
THAT IS ABOUT ALL WE KNOW.
I APOLOGIZE FOR THAT CONFUSION.
ALL OF THIS OCCURS THE SAME HOUR
THE UNITED STATES HAS SURPASSED
800,000 CORONAVIRUS CASES AS AT
THIS HOUR.
IN NEW YORK, BY THE WAY, 125
CASES, BY FAR THE HEAVIEST
NUMBER OF CASES IN NEW YORK.
NEW JERSEY IS AS DISTANT SECOND.
JUST THE SHEER NUMBER OF CASES
AND THE RATE OF INCREASE WHILE
COMING DOWN IS STILL GOING UP.
THAT IS SOMETHING WE WATCH A
VERY, VERY CLOSELY.
IT IS AMONG THE REASONS WHY WE
HAVE THIS MEASURE BEING VOTED ON
IN THE UNITED STATES SENATE SOON
TO GO TO THE HOUSE THAT WILL
CALL FOR STILL MORE BACKUP TO
HELP THOSE AFFECTED BY THIS
SHUTDOWN THAT’S BEEN GOING ON
THROUGHOUT MUCH OF THE COUNTRY.
THIS IS THE $484 BILLION MEASURE
OF THE SENATE EXPECTED TO EASILY
GET PAST THAT AND THEN IN THE
HOUSE.
BUT ALREADY WE’VE SEEN
BIPARTISANSHIP AGREEMENT
INCLUDING NANCY PELOSI AND
REPUBLICAN LEADERS ARE SAYING,
THIS IS ALL BUT A DONE DEAL.
MIKE EMANUEL HAS BEEN FOLLOWING
THE DRAMA ON CAPITOL HILL.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON.
ONCE THERE IS AN AGREEMENT
BETWEEN THOSE KEY PLAYERS ON
CAPITOL HILL AND SIGN UP AT THE
WHITE HOUSE, THINGS TEND TO MOVE
RATHER QUICKLY ON CAPITOL HILL.
IT IS RARE.
A LOT OF TIMES IT’S 20 OF
BICKERING.
THEY HAVE COME TOGETHER.
YOU HAD THE REPUBLICANS SAYING
THEY JUST WANTED TO EXTEND THAT
SMALL BUSINESS PROGRAM KNOWN AS
THE PAYCHECK PROTECTION PROGRAM
THAT HAD RUN OUT OF CASH.
DEMOCRATS AT THEIR OTHER
PRIORITIES THAT THEY WANTED TO
INCLUDE.
SO THEY ARE GOING TO GET
$25 BILLION.
THAT IS SOMETHING WE KNOW THAT
ANDREW CUOMO THE GOVERNOR OF
NEW YORK IS SPEAKING WITH THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
THIS AFTERNOON AND JUST WRAPPED
UP A SHORT TIME AGO.
A LOT OF CONCERNS ABOUT TESTING.
HOW DO YOU REOPENING THEIR
ECONOMY?
ALL INDICATIONS IS THE SENATE
SHOULD ACT IN A FEW MINUTES AND
PASS THIS MEASURE.
A LOT OF HOUSE LAWMAKERS ARE IN
THE PROCESS OF TRAVELING FROM
THEIR RESPECTIVE DISTRICTS BACK
TO CAPITOL HILL TO HAVE AT LEAST
A QUORUM FOR A VOTE ON THURSDAY
MORNING.
IT IS EXPECTED TO PASS THEIR
WITH THE SUNUP OF THE RELEVANT
LEADERS IN THE HOUSE, BUT THEY
HAVE TO HAVE AT LEAST A QUORUM
OF 216 OR SO MEMBERS AROUND TO
PASS IT AND SEND IT ON TO THE
PRESIDENT FOR HIS SIGNATURE,
NEIL.
>> Neil: HEY DUMB QUESTION ON
MY PART AND YOU’RE USE OF THEM.
THE TESTING THAT IS INCLUDED IN
THE LEGISLATION.
GOVERNOR CUOMO HAD ARGUED I
BELIEVE LAST WEEK AT THIS TIME
THAT, THAT IS A FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT RESPONSIBILITY.
HE LATER ACQUIESCED ON THAT IS
THAT HE WAS WRONG.
IT IS A STATE RESPONSIBILITY.
IF IT IS INCLUDED IN THIS
LEGISLATION, IN OTHER WORDS, TO
HELP STATES WITH MORE TESTING, I
GUESS IT BECOMES A MOOT POINT,
DOESN’T IT?
>> MY UNDERSTANDING IS PART OF
THE REASON THE GOVERNOR WANTED
TO SPEAK FACE-TO-FACE WITH THE
PRESIDENT RATHER THAN TALKING
PAST ONE ANOTHER IN MEDIA
APPEARANCES WAS TO SORT OUT,
WHAT IS THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
GOING TO COMMIT TO DOING IN
TERMS OF GREATER TESTING, AND
WHAT SHOULD GOVERNORS FOCUS ON
TO DO IN TERMS OF GREATER
TESTING?
OBVIOUSLY, IT IS IN >> NEEDS
INTEREST TO OPEN NEW YORK THE
KEY DRIVER IN ECONOMY.
IN THE NEW YORK CITY AREA,
PEOPLE LIVE ON TOP OF ONE
ANOTHER.
VERY CLOSELY TOGETHER.
THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
FEEL LIKE YOU CANNOT OPEN MASS
TRANSIT -- WHICH IS CRITICAL IN
NEW YORK CITY AND THE
SURROUNDING AREAS WITHOUT
KNOWING WHETHER HE WILL HAVE
BEEN TESTED AND WHETHER THEY ARE
CLEAR OR WHETHER MAY BE CARRYING
CORONAVIRUS.
IMAGINE CORONAVIRUS SPREADING
AROUND NEW YORK CITY SUBWAY
TRAINS.
OBVIOUSLY, THEY ARE NOT THERE
YET.
THE GOVERNOR WANTED TO SORT OUT
WITH THE PRESIDENT, WHAT IS THE
STATE’S RESPONSIBILITY?
WHAT IS THE FED’S
RESPONSIBILITY?
WE SHOULD GET MORE FROM THE
PRESIDENT WHEN HE DOES HIS DAILY